the most popular game from barstool
sports now available in the palm of your
hand
questions as [ __ ] up as you are in
your pocket download answer the internet
i'm tank sinatra and i'm going to answer
the internet would you rather be the
best looking dude in the world
or be able to read minds
um be the best looking dude in the world
a i'm not the best looking dude in the
world so that would be a step up b i
can't read minds anyway so i'm not
missing anything
c i don't need everyone thinking this
ugly [ __ ] in my face all the
time reading their mind
about how ugly i am i don't want that
either
it's a no-brainer would you rather fight
a kangaroo
or look like sam cassell so i don't even
know who sam cassell is
sam cassella i only know the jada kiss
line
because like sam i could sell yeah
that's it
that's what i look like now though oh no
you got the bald head that's
it um i'd rather fight i don't know this
is tough
i'd rather fight a kangaroo you could
become famous too like the guy who
punched the kangaroo
you don't have to win i mean you could
just get your ass kicked by a kangaroo
wow if you were reading the story of
your life
and you got to the present day would you
keep reading knowing you can't change
anything you read
some deep [ __ ] no no question
i had we were my partner
adam uh the creator and i were working
on something and it was around the time
that the powerball
was like 900 million and i asked him if
he was gonna play
and he goes absolutely not it's one of
the best things i ever heard in my life
i go why he goes
my story can't end like that i can't
work this hard for so many years in one
direction
and then have it all be made useless or
irrelevant by
getting more money than i would ever be
able to spend in my life and i was like
wow
that's a really interesting
[Laughter]
i'll just take my 900 million and put it
into what i've been working hard at
maniacs yeah but there's also a certain
satisfaction that comes from
earning money i would rather earn five
million than win
a billion and i know that sounds stupid
but they're all the same to me because i
don't have five million and i don't have
a billion so they're all abstract no i
understand what you're saying
just disagree
[Laughter]
would you rather would you go to a
football game at a 70 000 seat stadium
if you knew
such a stupid question
would you go to a football game at a 70
000 seat stadium
if you if you knew that 500 seats will
get ejected into a black hole
somehow but everyone who didn't get
ejected would get five million
those are good odds oh i didn't realize
that was the odds
i mean i would yes worst case scenario
you experience something nobody's ever
experienced before best case
you get 5 million bucks it would be
funny though if you're sitting there
like
500 out of 7 000 i'm good like you push
the button
[Laughter]
would you rather lose a leg or never be
able to have sex again
lose i mean lose a leg definitely
does anybody say well you are the only
person to ever be like there is
no alternative losing a leg is a [ __ ]
problem
dude you can't
walk ever again well you could get a
prosthetic yeah there are some solutions
but it's not fun
um i'm gonna stick with my answer now
i'm trying to picture humping with one
leg
seems difficult but i got strong upper
body
i'll figure it out a full-grown great
white
versus a full-grown polar bear in an
olympic-sized swimming pool
that is seven feet deep and 75 degrees
fahrenheit who wins
you know what i don't know a lot about
polar bears but i do know they're nasty
[ __ ] creatures
so i'm gonna say seven feet is
definitely enough room for the great
white to get some speed it doesn't say
how long or how
wide the pool is olympic size
oh [ __ ] great white
great white grey white i don't know i
think
i don't know a great i mean great white
i just watched jaws 20 times because my
son discovered it so i'm like very
versed in the whole great white ability
i mean the the mechanical thing i i know
is fake
jaws was also super aggressive the shark
might just run away for
up yeah uh i mean who would have thought
that the nicest looking of all the bears
would be the nastiest [ __ ]
of all the same thing with like pandas
will [ __ ] you up koalas
did you see the the town in saskatchewan
i think
where it came out recently that all the
doors on the cars and all the doors on
the homes are unlocked because
polar bears are such a problem that if a
one
one appears like you have to get into a
car so nobody locks their cars
nobody locks their front doors because
polar bears are such a huge problem why
live here
[Laughter]
what do you think is the oldest
someone's been when they've had sex
i know some some guys and they're
humping into their
90s i'll tell you what dude if i'm still
looking to get laid
after 80 we got a real problem
because like i i'm 80 i'm i'm cashing
out at like 45.
i can't keep up with this anymore when i
was working
in restaurants i remember seeing this
old woman reach for a glass
and i got so frustrated by her because i
was like
why are they so [ __ ] slow she was
like this
and i said that to somebody and they go
yo everything hurts and i was like oh
everything hurts so i guess like being
that old and
you know doing this is not an option
unless you just get in and
you know i'd say with at that age with
pain
cardiovascular coming into play you'd
have to i mean
80 is the max yeah i would say i don't
know i remember my uncle
jumped off the back of a pickup truck
when he was like 72. he probably still
was [ __ ]
we were moving my aunt and he jumped off
the back of the truck and i looked at my
dad i was like how old is he
72. would you rather your girlfriend be
able to read your thoughts during sex
or all the time except during sex oh man
um i
i'm married so my wife i would rather
be able to read my mind during sex
because it's i can like at least i have
something to focus on and concentrate
if anybody anybody had access to my
thoughts
all the time i would be murdered or in
jail
100 there's no question and nobody would
come near me i would have no friends
and it's not through there there are no
fault of my own the mind is just a
wasteland of
garbage man you see
so much so much i mean i take in a lot i
try and take in as much
positivity as i can but i've had some
times where i'm sitting there thinking
about something and i'm like
wow you're [ __ ] up
yeah i don't need anybody reading my
thoughts sex i mean sex is what
three minutes i also speak my mind
during sex
so having my wife read my mind is not
that much different than what
what happens now you know i won't tell
you guys what
yeah uh what's better being a cowboy or
pirate
i'm gonna say a pirate just because
i feel like riding a horse all day would
suck
and you're out of the desert like that's
what i think of when i think of cowboy
when i think of pirate
i think of being on the seas i mean the
seas are rough too but at least like
at least just like some kind of exotic
feel to being out on the ocean being in
the desert
i just came from that area i was out in
new mexico and utah
and in between cities is miserable
miserable would you rather
remember my wife i mentioned um would
you rather bang a bunch of models but
nobody knows
or not actually [ __ ] them but have
everyone think you did
um i would rather bang a bunch of models
but nobody knows
because i'll have that in my memory
forever
because i actually did it that this to
me is like would you rather be
rich but not famous or famous but not
rich and i can tell you from having like
a little bit of
internet fame and not being rich there's
nothing worse than people knowing who
you are
bothering you writing you dms telling
you they're
you know to die or whatever and not
having money to tell them to go [ __ ]
themselves yes
so being rich and not famous is way
better so i would say i'd rather better
the bottles than nobody knows
especially my wife
you